we were just talking about this you know
the car that you wanted when you were
growing up and a lot of people wait
people call it a midlife crisis but it
just you have the money at what people
would consider your midlife and then you
know 26 you can't buy your dream car at
50 you might be able to we call it a
midlife crisis the car you wanted when
you were a teenager fitzy was what it
was the electric-blue iroc-z that had
that eagle on the front I loved that was
that an eagle or set a Firebird maybe
was a Firebird yeah I guess it was more
of a fun was it I think it was like gold
with the wings yeah you're probably but
yeah the specifically electric blue I
rock I thought that was hot shetan I
always liked Porsches
yeah but when I was really young I
always thought a 911 was the coolest
thing but again a little older like a
speedster those are pretty great
convertible Paulie mid seventies red
Corvette Oh
McLovin something where the doors opened
upward a little the gold ring yeah yeah
I wanted a big-block I wanted one of
those muscle cars because I grew up with
guys who had muscle cars like Chevelle
396 chevelles Road Runners like I had
some guys who had some great cars Nick
Saban set to join us Continental Tire
Coach's Corner let me start with that
question there coach
growing up in high school what was the
car that you wanted well I worked at my
dad service station so I used to see
from the time I was 11 years old so
every time a heart katkar came out but
it was a GTO or the you know 442 cutlass
supreme or you know it sees some kind of
you know Mercedes 280 SL go by you're
like wow man I'd love to have a car like
that someday but my favorite car growing
up was the jaguar xk e 12 or whatever
that had no wire wheels a two-seat
convertible that was probably my
all-time favorite did you ever buy one
of those cars that you wanted when you
were a teenager yeah I was actually good
and you know probably made some
financial mistakes don t live in large
weight would you buy when they could
stop making the 1973 which I think I was
my
might have been in my first year of
coaching they stopped making the Jaguar
XKE so there was only like 25 left in
the country so I said I won't get one of
these don't ever be able to get one
again so I could afford that like a hole
in it you know are you good with your
carcass I mean you do all your work
since you worked in a garage oh not
anymore
you know I think that you know I know
enough to get one started when I start
and things like that but you know the
technology on cars is completely
different now with all the
computerization of you know technology
it doesn't even mean these things don't
even have carburetors anymore so it's
completely different so you know having
the two Mercedes dealerships are part of
them I don't have anything to do with
them but I Drive those cars and the
technology on those I can't even figure
out how to do anything except to turn
the radio on and off do you watch do you
binge watch TV
not really what what I guess my favorite
thing to do is I do watch ESPN I like to
catch up on what's happening in sports
maybe long enough to get the news you
know primarily but you know Terry and I
like to get an old Netflix series or
something the way I work whenever I'm
home for an hour we can watch an episode
so that's kind of how we operate and
that may go on for months so that's not
it's about how it goes with us what TV
show on Netflix oh you know whatever we
can find that's good
peaky blinders is one that we watched
rain we were like historical things you
know old-fashioned things so we used to
record the the Old English movie where
they lived in a big castle I don't even
remember the name of it that Downton
Abbey about Nabby yeah you know Terry
likes that stuff so I kind of you know I
get home 10:30 at night I
45 minutes of chill out before I go to
bed that's kind of what we do what do
you think when you see yourself though
on ESPN do you watch yourself if they
show clips of you at a press conference
I know I change the channel how would
you describe your relationship with the
media oh well I guess to really get that
idea you'd have to ask some of the media
folks but I think with some people I
have a really good relationships with
they have a pretty understanding of who
I am what I'm all about why I do things
the way we do them all and then there's
other people who probably aren't so
pleased with it and I think that sort of
goes with the territory but the one
thing I do try to do with the media is
which there was a time when I first
became a head coach right and realized
the importance of this is you know be
very respectful of the job that they're
trying to do and appreciate that and
that they sort of are the link to the
fans and provide a lot of information
and create a lot of interest you know
for our sport and the players that play
it so we always try to be very
respectful that group
he's Nick Saban Alabama head coach
joining his Continental Tire Coach's
Corner but I was trying to understand
your press conference the other day when
you sort of went off on a variety of
topics and it had to do with you know
your linebacker Christian Miller and
then I was told by a college football
reporter who said you misread Nick he
was having fun with those members of the
media were you having fun yeah I I think
sometimes you know my sense of humor is
mistaken yeah it's amazing to me and I
don't really think it's fair to the
players so now I think one of the things
that especially our local media does is
they create this tremendous expectation
for you know some of our players young
players who come in with reputations
players who have been in the program but
you know immediately sent an expectation
for that sky is going to be a phenomenal
player but the guy really hasn't ever
played yet well I I think two things I
don't think that's fair to the player
because I think it creates an
unrealistic expectation and increase a
lot of anxiety for some of these guys so
I kind of get on the guys for doing that
I mean in a way in a fun way I know
their their job and their creating some
news and interest in the player but I
also think sometimes that's unfair for
the player but it's a compliment to you
coach well but I'm not so we're much
worried about me as I am you know the
players that play on our team and how we
can help them be successful personally
academically and athletically and I
don't think sometimes people realize how
these guys are just college student
athletes that and how they get affected
by you know things that are out there
and there's a lot of social media but
there's a lot of media that creates some
of these you know images and
expectations and look I'm realizing it's
a blessing to be coaches Alabama it's a
blessing to be a player here it's a
blessing to have the opportunity to get
an education do the things plan and kind
of games we plan but it also is a burden
that comes with all that you know in
terms of your responsibility to
represent in the first-class way and I
just and hey we all accept that and I
want our players to accept that so but I
also don't want them to create a lot of
anxiety about it or expectations that
were created for them describe your
level of interest with the solar eclipse
today not much you know it's going to be
a I know there's a lot of interest just
going to go right over our house at like
Burton and Clayton Georgia we may be the
only empty house at the lake it's going
to last for two minutes and I'm sure
it'll be a memorable experience for a
lot of people and then everybody's going
to say that's it
did you did you see the poll on CBS
sports that had you the second most
overrated coach behind Jim Harbaugh
anonymous coach's poll did you even hear
about this and do you even care I mean
what was your reaction to that well you
know first of all I probably agree with
that I mean the success that we have is
has really contributed to by a lot of
people then we have really good coaches
we got a really good staff of people who
work with the players we've had a
tremendous amount of really really good
players who have made a tremendous
commitment you know to a standard of
excellence that you know has created a
lot of success here so I I feel like I
get far too much credit for that and so
I would probably tend to agree with
whoever voted that way to be honest with
you I'll leave you with this
would you rather ease into the season or
I know you're not easing into the season
this year with Florida State but you
know that traditionally it you know
teams would ease into the season that's
not happening anymore what do you think
of that philosophy well we've had that
philosophy now for 10 years ever since
we've been here resulted up in one of
these you know sort of national games
that at first when we were here because
we didn't have a really good program I
thought it was important to get a lot of
exposure when I learned from the games
is when you play a really good opponent
the first game is the players are much
more interested in the offseason the
spring practice summer conditioning fall
camp preparation everybody has their
attention because of who they're playing
in the first game I say about talked
about internally as coaches in terms of
helping them develop them
and I do think that it lets you know you
know where you are as a team what you
need to improve on because you played a
really good team and you know sometimes
even though it's a big game much better
not to have success early in the season
later on so this can sort of put a put a
good perspective for every individual on
your team as to what you need to do to
have the kind of team you want a house
coach have fun today
keep stirring it up with the media there
we appreciate your time
okay Dan thank you buddy see you bye bye
it's uh coach Nick Saban there yep I
call you buddy yeah he might do that for
everybody I don't know I thought I heard
maybe not the local media in Alabama
Continental Tire Coach's Corner
Continental try the official tire major
league soccer soccer fans expect peak
performance on the pitch and also demand
peak performance on the street as well
that's why continental else be able to
tire for what you do no matter what
you're doing they've got the best tire
for you the best in class wet braking
superb handling tires Continental Tire
crowd supported the Dan Patrick show
visit Continental Tire dot-com for more
the Dan Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience